hallo
die liebe die so sage ich hau dir
herzlich willkommen hier zu einem
weiteren command heute am dienstagabend
nacht mehr oder weniger ich glaube das
video mit viel glück kommt es noch vor
zehn uhr online es tut mir leid kommt
früher ganz einfach ich habe heute
wirklich den kompletten tag am buch
gearbeitet was ich letztens schon mal
angekündigt hat und zwar kommt ja von
mir bald irgendwann oktober/november
september in dem um den drehen buch raus
mit command mit sex mit fakten über mich
mit fakten über andere youtuber mit pvp
strategien von anderen youtube an und
crafting ideen und lala blablabla
deswegen tut es mir so unfassbar leid
dass dieses videos heute haben zu spät
dran kam er wird den ganzen tag in wie
produktiv beschäftigt und das ist
irgendwie schön aus so mit dem mit dem
strand und dem wasser und ich weiß also
viele sagen immer luca dafür dass alles
schön es ist auch so es ist einfach
schön es sieht einfach schön aus oder
anfang erstmal an endlich mit dem
command und zwar der command von jappy
gutachten 19 und 20 captain america
command ja richtig gehört
und zwar geht das hier eindrücke auf
fertig und die gesetzlich beispielsweise
ein red storm blog mal eben daneben den
hierzu wieder entfernen dann sehen wir
schon wenn dieses ding da oben den
anderen red storm blog erreicht bauen
eine maschine und dann ist auch hier
diese maschine gesprochen die es da oben
jetzt ich glaube ich auch zugebaut genau
hat sich jetzt auch zugebaut und dann
kann man halt entweder sagen führt ihr
typ die squeezebox oder captain america
belgrad 98 oder weil wieder habe ich
eigentlich uns sagen und man sieht hier
im inventar im chat schon klick hier to
download the soft pack und zwar braucht
man darf ein respekt weil braucht man
sonst resource pack genau eigentlich
immer minister carretto den commander
mister gay pride parade oder und ja
dieser command ist mit hilfe von vista
gewässer entstanden und zwar dinge wie
das captain america schielt und so was
alles wurde von mister charakterdesign
allerdings habe ich mir natürlich als
fleißiger vorbereitung des touchpad
runtergeladen das heißt wenn resource
paquin packen des tracks raus und packen
diamond captain america reinklicken auf
fertig und dann sehen wir schon haben
wir jetzt eigentlich ein default action
pack allerdings wenn wir uns jetzt mal
hier beim kampf dings umschauen sehen
wir schon hier sonst diamant sachen und
sowas und jetzt eigentlich dass ihr mann
schwert aller sind links sind dass wir
jetzt alles
captain america sachen das heißt wir
haben ja seine schuhe wir haben seine
hose wir haben sein großvater seinen
helm und auf seinen diamant schwert
yaman schwert mehr oder weniger sein
captain america spielt und wenn ich als
beispielsweise mir die stiefel man hier
seht ihr schon habe die sprungkraft und
kann jetzt besonders hoch springen wenn
ich mir beispielsweise die schule noch
die hosen anhaben schnelligkeit das
heißt wenn ich sprinte bin ich viel
schneller sieht man auch schon hier ich
bin jetzt viel schneller wenn ich hose
und schuhe anhaben kann auch höher
springen das sieht man denke ich dann
wenn ich mir noch den brustpanzer ans
hier habe ich auch noch stärke das heißt
wenn ich jemand schlag ist ja fast
direkt tot wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
hier zudem tinten für schwimmen und
einfach mal zwei mal auf den
draufschlagen beispielsweise einfach
schon tot
tuut tuut tuut ader und ford will
okay die tonleiter sich diese kudarat
getötet habe dann seht ihr auf jeden
fall habe ich hier schon die stärke mit
am start und wenn ich den beispielsweise
noch die diamanten helm aufsetze seht
ich schon habe ich alle das heißt wenn
ich jetzt irgendwas abbauen wie
beispielsweise im game mode 0 mal einen
band bloc dann geht das ganze viel
schneller oder ein erdloch
da sollte man eigentlich leben dass er
schneller geht das ist auch ganz gut
dass ich jetzt schon in dem game ott 0
mich befinde und zwar seht ihr schon
jetzt habe ich die stärke wenn ich dann
allerdings das diamant schwert an wähle
seht ihr schon ist die stärke weg also
dieses captain america schielt und jetzt
sieht das ganze auch mega cool aus ich
sehe wirklich einfach aus wie captain
america und ich kann auch beispielsweise
mein schwert wegschmeißen und es kommen
die dazu möchte zurückkommen oder nicht
sie halt einfach aus wie captain america
und mein schild bleibt hier liegen genau
da ist es und ich habe halt auch viele
funktionen also die stärke wird quasi
ersetzt immer wenn ich das diamant
schwert an behle
dieses diamant schwert hat halt schon
richtig krasse schaden das profi wenn
dann noch die stärke drauf wäre wenn ich
weg switche habe ich dann halt die
stärke das heißt dann kann ich mit der
hand ein paar mops töten um mit dem mit
dem diamant schwert hier mit dem diamant
schwert sage ich mal so nett war ich
nenne mal captain america mit seinem mit
seinem captain mit seinem marica spielt
heißt es ist denn eigentlich neues
captain america schild hielt burkhard
riepenhoff und der captain america wird
halt mit diesem schild ist es ist halt
einfach ein diamant schwert und er kann
damit einerseits ich suche schon die
ganze zeit habe ich finde einfach keine
ok krass hier sind tatsächlich einfach
gar keine mops am start
ich weiß nicht woran es liegt aber
irgendwie haben die wohl alle sorgen so
ein bisschen respekt vor mir oder ich
meine wenn wenn doch ihr kleiner ist
dann heißt es doch ja jackpot ganz viel
kür don't [ __ ] you
was soll denn jetzt verbringt
triple gehabt gerade auch schon das
perfekte beispiel gesehen dass ich habe
das ding weg geschmissen und es ist
zurückgekommen und es hat drei tiere
getötet das ist nämlich das maximum was
erreicht werden kann also dass man es
wegwirft es tötet drei mops im umkreis
und kommt dann wieder zu einem zurück
wenn ich allerdings ist beispielsweise
mit dem game und 1 zurück gehe um
beispielsweise dieses schild auch die
cooler schmeiße und jetzt weg fliege
seht ihr schon bleibt das schild dort
einfach liegen weil ich mich außerhalb
des umkreises von diesem schild befinden
und dann bleibt es halt einfach neben
dem getöteten entity liegen und das war
eigentlich schon der komplette command
ich hatte zwar eigentlich gesagt dass an
dienstagen im moment kommen die sehr
umfangreich sind diesen hätte man
natürlich auch in einer normalen folge
am freitag benutzen können allerdings
habe ich den jetzt einfach genommen weil
er mir vorgeschlagen wurde in den
kommentaren unter der commands folge und
ich es wirklich ich bin total gestresst
den ganzen tag gewesen ich freue mich
dass jetzt einfach hier sitzen ganz
schön video aufnehmen kann
ich habe zurzeit mega nasen schmerzen in
die närrinnen seit ich weiß nicht woran
das liegt ich hoffe euch auf jeden fall
dass euch das video gefallen hat und ihr
mit der mod mit dem command ding
wemdings zufrieden seid wenn ihr jetzt
getan habt werden tun daumen hoch geben
eventuell main kanal abonnieren mehr
command sehen wollt und noch nicht
abonnieren von meinem kanal weit
ja wenn ihr weitere commands kennt
schreibt seine kommentare und dann sehen
wir uns freut euch aufs buch es wird
sehr sehr geil